this is not a thing I tried to do a hair
thing is this is not a hair thing it's
something oh man hats are great more
important style tips like that in my new
style guide Grayson style they are two
pretending you have it available for pre
sale now at great style book calm which
is some of the stuff I wanted to talk to
you guys about today um the book Wow
could I be more of my own aesthetic
right now it's going to show you guys
that I made a smoothie you don't even
need to know if it tastes good I made
this I'm better than you
greatness now they aren't pretending you
haven't is a book that I'm very very
proud about and my pride like a group of
lions that rapidly reproduce grows every
day did that make sense no more things
that might not make sense found in my
new style guide Grace's that I refer to
do you have it I like this book so much
that I wanted to make sections of it
available for you guys before it
actually comes out so you can get
excited about it you can maybe be
convinced to buy it if you are not
totally convinced yet or you can feel
complete regret from pre-ordering it the
world is your oyster I hope not that's a
tiny little world why is that a saying
the world is your oyster there might be
a pearl inside or various deep sea so
please make sure I have all this
information correctly you guys say yes
classically I don't ever see know what
I'm talking about
remember I'm bender so I've created a
Wattpad profile if you don't know what
Wattpad is educate yourself there are so
many tools for education these days
I'm not a tool don't I don't I'm just
straight up lying more lies then my new
style guide Grace and style the art of
pretending you have it okay is it a
wonderful website that I will be sharing
with you some excerpts from my book
before it comes out on February 2nd it's
going to show you some colors what why
what it's a book white pad calm such
grace helbig in the book there are
different sections called vintage grace
which are stories from my past that have
to do with different ways I've
experienced style and the one that is
currently available for you on that
Wattpad profile is called vintage grace
shopping lessons from my father and it
is all about the first time that my dad
went to the limited - when I was in
middle school and he told me I could
pick out anything I wanted for my
birthday and the emotional rollercoaster
that that was I'll read you just a quick
little section when I was in sixth grade
the limited to was the shopping mecca
girls were made and betrayed by that
innocent bubble that her fought with the
flower in the logo if you shopped at
limited - you were hot [ __ ] I'm probably
too young to use the phrase hot [ __ ]
colloquially for those of you unfamiliar
limited to is the teen / tween branch of
the women's clothing store the limited
it had all the most colorful trends that
in clothes an upper middle-class
suburban girl could dream of I'll let
you guys read the rest of it on my wall
pet profile again Wattpad calm such
grace helbig go follow it go create a
Wattpad account because it's a really
great platform for us to share more
conversations about the book in January
and there will be new excerpts from the
book
there again Wattpad commish grace helbig
reading - the chapter of vintage great
shopping lessons for my father let me
know what you guys think when you follow
me we'll be able to communicate about
all of the updates having to do with the
book including book tour which I will be
announcing next year we're figuring out
all of the specifics for it and I am so
excited because are some things planned
that are different than last time that I
think will be so great or they won't be
great Pandora's box the world is your
oyster
Paul so in addition to all that stuff
about the book I thought it might be
nice to do a very abbreviated favorites
for you because these are some of my
favorite things that I have been
enjoying currently that have to do with
both beauty and style so let's just jump
right into it you don't have to jump you
have weak knees I know knee pads huge
spring 2016
maybe yeah yes yeah you say I can't say
ah tarts for true blues bronze and black
gel liner but oh wow could I be more
color-blocked right now shiny think of a
joke that Duke cock-blocked and
color-blocked know I love this gel
eyeliner but even more I love this brush
that came with it will it focus oh my
god this camera see how it's bent like
that like I stepped on it I didn't step
on it I probably will at some point in
the future step on it but the brush is
bent so it makes it easier to do your
eye look I did that I did that I'm a
huge huge fan of it also this gel liner
is very great to use and I haven't
really seen brown gel liner I haven't
used it yet but I'm curious and
curiosity murdered a cat so should be
fun yeah yeah can see yeah PST this is
actually excitement in Schuster ku
published my book that made a whole like
care package for the holidays of made
well stuff that I could use on my book
tour next year and they sent me these
third losses in this beautiful leather
sunglass case how sophisticated like Who
am I
someone with their sugar look at that
Wow
I could be doing anything right now
Wow very John Lennon but not care about
snacks yeah kiss me I can't be out this
is a purse that I got from Zara that I
love usually I carry either a very small
clutch or a way too big bag and this is
kind of in between but on the smaller
side and it has a strap so I can do so
much stuff with my honor
it's like watch I could do anything and
it's got like the perfect amount of room
inside it's got a pocket it's also got a
little zip pocket on the front so that I
put a ticket in - OH - kinky boots look
tickets can fit in it
Wow I also like the quilted kind of
pleather pattern and it wasn't that
expensive I do not remember exactly how
much it was but I remember it not being
crazy expensive look at this that was
American Sign Language for please follow
me on Wattpad that prompts us for
something yeah these yeah yeah yeah
hey oh that's so good there it just they
move you guess what I am
Budi send the Blowfish in the wintertime
I love a good booty who doesn't people
that are more of a boob person I guess
and these are really great these are
from Topshop and they're very simple
they go with tons of stuff they don't
have a huge heel which is very easy to
do it for me
and they got a cute little buckle right
there they're just so easy to slide on
and off cuz they got this stretchy
material it's like Spanx for your
cankles again don't remember how much
they were but they weren't crazy
expensive but that also depends on your
definition of crazy expensive they were
more than a Payless BOGO sale but less
than a house cute that's cute yeah yeah
I think this has been in a favorites
video before but I just found it again
in one of my purses and I loved it it's
the buxom bu exo-m for lip cream in
White Russian
and oh that's why it smells like that it
smells amazing
and it's just kind of but didn't detect
so it's good to move your mouth while
you're putting lip gloss or on your
mouth Beauty hair doesn't really make
too much of a difference
my favorite kind of beauty products
melts amazing so that is great in one
respect but also terrible because you
just want to eat it all the time because
as females we are no self-control
yeah obviously this is one of my
favorites for this month and for like
the next six months so get ready for
this degree in your face a lot oh I want
to show you let me show you one of my
favorite photos the photos were shot by
Robin shoots at Robin shoots who shot my
first book and I shot a bunch of other
photos for me and she's wonderful
yeah what does it mean you have to get
the book to find out I mean there you go
I hope this was interesting girl ball I
don't know lot pad comes with grace
Helbig grace style book calm